all
what are we doing with
this bicycle is a call from
citizens for citizens to be
encourage to use the bicycle and put
to celebrate it, to celebrate it as a bicycle
a recreational tool like a
tool that generates health with a
tool that favors the economy
no no no no
and here we have 5 million vehicles
circulating five and a half then obviously
we have a high risk factor and if
we got to have days like
previous ones where there is a scarce one
scarce presence of high winds
concentration of ultraviolet rays and
this generates as a consequence a
high concentration of ozone so let's
keep having these conditions
of pollution is affecting
too much not only in the physical aspect
but also in the emotional because this
it causes a lot of stress a problem
Very strong
No it's not